situé en forêt un espace avec des
espèces indigènes et endémiques de la
réunion est l'objectif de cette activité
ici au bonheur des enfants cessé de
faire découvrir à tous
en apportant des notions très simple on
parle de trésors quand on parle des
plantes indigènes et endémiques et on
essaye de leur faire acquérir un réflexe
qui est de retrouver le une plante grâce
à la forme de la feuille voilà donc on
fait un jeu d'ombrés chinoises
j'essaye de retrouver la forme de la
feuille ensuite le nom commun en parle
pas des noms latins sur des notions très
simple donc le nom commun de la plante
voilà pour qu'ils puissent petit à petit
acquérir des connaissances concernant le
patrimoine végétal naturel de la réelle
avec mao remparts et le jan pas tout
c'était bien mais que les fans aussi
le patron c'est pas facile à les
reconnaître on a appris que parents et
pommes sont pas pareils alors question
ça veut dire quoi endémique
c'est elle
juste parce que les fleurs passé mois ci
les faire bouger
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous en tant
que animateurs on est en compétition
avec les consoles de jeux vidéo les
ordinateurs internet et le le fait de
réussir à les accrocher sur des
thématiques comme ça ça donne beaucoup
d'espoir puisque là on parle de
conservation du patrimoine végétal donc
se rend compte qu un engouement réel
pour tous ces thématiques et bien c'est
ça ça me fait très plaisir